okay sit
down good boy hi everybody
welcome to the show that's douglas we're
going to be talking about pet adoptions
in a minute um and he's a rescue and hi
i want to say really quickly immediately
to the bffs how are you guys
hi oh my goodness i see a fresh
baby and you sir looked just like
everybody that was friends with my
parents growing up and i see doggies
and oh everybody looks so
beautiful oh there's drew sweatshirts
you bought some of the swag from the
store i'm
so impressed you guys look so awesome
i'd actually like to throw you guys a
question uh
jan i heard you're an rv enthusiast
i'm an rv enthusiast there you are
they're back yes we
took a road trip across country um
no prior experience with an rv and had a
blast
by the way and you look good doing it
jan
thank you yeah like yellow top
leaf mother of pearl earrings i'm
beautiful hair
wow you're very inspiring thank you
well thank you for bonding on rvs i
actually had a cross-country trip
the first one i took was with my partner
of 25 years in flower films nancy javon
and fallon
i pulled some pictures these are
polaroids because 25 years ago that was
how we took pictures
um as you all know and that's us that's
me with my dog templeton i've always had
rescues
um so this is my first rescue templeton
there's nan washing the windshield
because
you go through we went through deserts
and mountains and we would flip
quarters at intersections and be like
should we go right or go left we went to
dollywood
i ripped off the entire air conditioning
unit by getting stuck
under a gas station overhang in the
middle of the night
in new orleans
and then we got stuck there for a few
days it was actually really fun thank
you cajun campers for helping us
um it was
nuts um but i think what's so
nice about rvs and why i'm so glad that
they're making a comeback is
you like it you stay you don't
i have a laundry basket with me and
there's just that beautiful freedom
and the choice and you're not bogged
down well we all
can't really travel right now but you
know
it's just there's a way of life to an rv
that's unlike real life and normal life
so
i always rented from uh cruise america
actually and you would literally
like go on you know you can go on the
internet now and pick you can pick it up
somewhere and drop it off somewhere it's
a fantastic program
you